>>> THIS MORNING, A FLORIDA
DOCTOR ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THIS PANDEMIC HAS TEMPOLYD CUST
4-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER BECAUSE OF
HER PROXIMITY TO CORONAVIRUSTHD
EMERGENCY ORDER AND THE JUDGE
RULED IN FAVOR SAYINGQUOTE, IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE MINOR CHILD,
THIS COURT TEMPORARILY SUSPENDS
THE FORMER WIFE'S TIME SHARING.
IT'S SOLELY RELATED TO THE
OUTBREAK OF COVID-19.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE DOCTOR AND
MOTHER GOING THROUGH THIS.
DR. TERESA GREEN.
SHE'S AN EMERGENCY MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH USND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THIS PANDEMIC.
EVERYONE APPRECIATES WHAT YOU'RE
DOING.
YOU'RE APPEALING THE JUDGE'S
ORDER.
YOU CALL IT DISCRIMINATORY.
WHY?
>> IF I WAS MARRIED AND I HAD
BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
HOME TO MY CHILD, NO ONE COULD
TELL ME I SHOULDN'T DO THAT.
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
YOU KNOW, MY BROTHER WORKS -- IS
AN ENGINEER, HE'S BUILDING THE
HOSPITALS UP IN NEW YORK.
HE GETS TO COME HOME TO HIS TWO
KIDS.
WE HAVE G EVIDENCE THAT HAS
REALLY MADE ME FEEL BETTER IN
STICKING BY THE -- THAT SHOWS
CHILDREN ARE MINIMALLY AFFECTED
BY THIS DISEASE.
AND THATEALTH CARE WORKERS WHO
USE PROPER PRECAUTIONS ARE NOT
AT AN INCREASE FOR THE VII THINR
A JUDGE TO TELL ME I CAN'T COME
HOME TO MY CHILD.
>> YOUR DAUGHTER IS JUST FOUR
YEARS OLD.
HOW MUCH DOES SHE UNDERSTAND
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW?
>> SHET.
SHE DOESN'T.
SHE KNOWS MOMMY IS SAD.
I HAVE BEEN FOR A COUPLE DAYS
BEFORE I GAVE HER UP.
YOU KNOW, I SAID TO HER, I DON'T
KNOW NOT SEE YOU FOR A LONG
TIME.
SHE SAID, I'LL SEE YOU FRIDAY.
IT WAS FRIDAY.
SHE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND AND
REALLY WORRY ABOUT THE TOLL IT
TAKES ON HER.
YOU KNOW, BY MEANS AM IAN
EXPERT IN CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH.
READING STUDIES THAT CHILDREN
SUFFER SIGNIFICANT PSYCHOLOGICAL
DAMAGE.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO GET IN
TODAY.
THE NUMBER ONE PREDICTOR OF
LONG-TERM MENTAL HEALTH
CHILDREN
[ INAUDIBLE ]
USUALLY THE JUDGE WOULD RESPECT
THE RIGHTS OF BOTH PARENTS TO BE
PRESENT IN A CHILD'S LIFE.
THIS IS A RASH DECISION I THINK
IN NOTG THAT WITHOUT AT
LEAST HEARING THE EVIDENCE.
>> I WANT TO READ YOU A
STATEMENT FROM THE ATTORNEY OF
YOUR EX-HUSBAND.
IT SAYS, MR. GREENE AND I HAVE
RESPECT FOR DR.
GREENE'S COMMITMENT TO HER
CRITICAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
THE TEMPORARY TIME SHARING
DISPUTE WAS PRESENTED BEFORE THE
COURT AND A DECISION REACHED ON
MINOR CHILD LIMITED TO THE
TEMPORARY CIRCUMSTANCES
PRESENTED BY COVID-19.
PURSUANT TO MR. GREENE'S REQUEST
IN THIS ORDER BY THE COURT,
SHE'S TO HAVE DAILY VIDEO
COMMUNICATION WITH THE CHILD.
WE BELIEVEHE
ACHIEVED SAFELY AND FAIRLY.
THE SUGGESTION THERE IS THAT
THIS IS ABOUT THE SAFETY OF YOUR
DAUGHTER.
THERE WILL BE THOSE WHO LOOK AT
THIS AND SAY, THIS IS ABOUT THE
CHILD'S SAFETY.
SHE SHOULDN'T BE NEAR,
QUOTE-UNQUOTE CORONAVIRUS.
HOW ARE YOU GUARANTEEING OR HOW
DID YOU PLAN TO GUARANTEE THAT
SHE WAS SAFE FROM CORONAVIRUS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE HAVE
ADEQUATE PPE.
I HAVE BEEN SEEING CORIR
PATIENTS SINCE APPROXIMATELY
MARCH 12th AND MAYBE UNKNOWINGLY
BEFORE THAT.
WE'VE UTILIZED THE FULL PPE.
VE PRACTICING MEDICINE
FOR 18 YEARS NOW.
I KNOW WHAT I'M DOING.
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE THAT I'VE
ENCOUNTERED.YES, IT IS SEVERE A
DANGER.
WE'RE BEING VERY CAREFUL.
I MEAN, THE TONE AT W
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
WE'RE CAREFUL ABOUTTH
TOUCH.
I'M ACTUALLY A GERMOPHOBE.
WE USE EVERYTHING WE CAN.
WE GO BEYOND TO PROTECT MYSELF
AND MY CHILD.
HOME, I STRIP DOWN IN THE
CARPORT, I TAKE A SHOWER.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER, MY
DAUGHTER IS NOT USUALLY HERE
WHEN I'M WORKING.
WE HAVE A SCHEDULE SET UP SO K
DON'T HAVE HER.
SHE WON'T BE EXPOSED IN THAT
WAY.
I HOPE TO NOT CONTRACT THE
VIRUS.
>> DO YOU FEEL YOU'RE BEINGED T?
>> IT'S A REALLY, REALLY TOUGH
PLACE TO BE IN.
I DO.
I THINK THAT THE POSITION I'VE
BEEN LEFT WI
I THINK IT'S NOT FAIR.
IT'S USING MY CHILD.
I WON'TNDON MY TEAM AT WORK
OR THE PATIENTS WHO WIL L TO
ME TO SAVE THEIR LIVES IN THE
COMING WEEKS.
BUT IT'S TORTURE.
I THINK MY DAUGHTER, I WANT HER
TOER TO BE PROUD OF ME
BY PROVIDING --
[ INAUDIBLE ]
BUT I ALSO KNOW SHE NEEDS ME
NOW.
>> WHEN DO YOU THINK YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO SEE HER AGAIN? I DON'T .
I MEAN, THE JUDGE ALSO DIDN'T
GIVE AN END DATE.
I REALLY DO HOPE THAT THIS IS
OVERTHROWN.
OR OVERTURNED.
SORRY.
BUT I REALLY HAVE NO CERTAINTY
THERE AND IT'S THE END OF THE
PANDEMIC, NO CAN SAY WHEN
THAT WILL BE.
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY
DISCRETION OF THIS JUDGE.
>> DR. GREENE, WE'RE SORRY
YOU'RE GOING THROUGH THIS.
WE THANK YOU FOR THE WORK YOU
ARE DOING IN SAVING LIVES ON
FRONT LINE OF THIS PANDEMIC.
WE HOPE THERE IS SOME RESOLUTION
TO THIS.
THAN